last summer Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson called President Trump a [ __ ]
and then was talked out of resigning by
Mike Pence he called him a [ __ ] and
then Mike Pence talked him out of
resigning yeah pence his exact words
were don't quit that [ __ ] needs you we
need that [ __ ] Prince Harry and you
know this everyone's talking about his
relationship
uh-huh no with megyn Markel yeah okay
historians say could you pretend to care
was that okay now and that when I was
taking your word for it yeah
I'm telling you historians say that if
Prince Harry marries his girlfriend
Meghan Markel it'll be groundbreaking
for the British royal family
groundbreaking that's what they said
yeah that's right yeah not not because
Markel is of mixed race but because
they're not related now that's the part
that's the part
blowing people's minds in Pennsylvania
this man's incredible story in
Pennsylvania a pro-life congressman a
pro-life congressman is accused of
asking his mistress to get an abortion
so his wife wouldn't find out about his
affair he's pro-life yeah he defended
himself saying hey when I said I'm
pro-life I meant I'm Pro my life okay
let's get something straight I look out
for number one
that's what I do
Byron Scott a former coach of the Lakers
had his home broken into and money and
valuables stolen yeah afterwards Scott
said it could be worse
I could still be the coach of the Lakers
that's an odd react it's really not a
good team yeah
former boxing champion George Foreman
has challenged former action star Steven
Seagal to fight him in the ring and the
winner will be our next president yeah
that's how it works now in France
someone has installed I'm not making
this up someone has installed the
first-ever raw oyster vending machine a
raw oyster vending machine yeah yeah
it's being called innovative by seafood
lovers and the best idea ever
by bacteria bacteria loves it didn't
suck let's please thank you one guy Wow
I could hear my heart beating on that
one I'm standing by that joke I like
that yeah yeah you're not gonna get me
down about that joke but good god it was
a quiet you rarely hear just in the
world just try and find a place in the
world yeah that's that quiet it was like
as this studio was and I said really
loved by bacteria like like a walk in
the woods no even in the woods you hear
the crackle right of maybe a twig
underfoot or maybe a car car of a bird
this was a kind of quiet you just don't
hear in life and we made it happen
together
[Applause]
you